hi there welcome back to the future of
documents i'm holt skinner and i'm a
developer advocate for google cloud
in the last video we learned about how
to start using document ai with the
cloud console and api
now let's take a deep dive into general
processors these are pre-trained and
ready-to-use models designed to work on
just about any document
these are a great starting point for
many document processing needs
[Music]
currently we have three general
processors available document ocr form
parser and document quality let's say
you have a scanned copy of a document it
can be typed or handwritten and you want
to extract all the text from this
document you simply submit the document
to the document ocr processor and it
will return you the extracted text from
that document
on the right hand side you have a
scanned copy of the document and on the
left you have the extracted text from
document ocr
the document ocr processor is able to
extract text correctly even from images
of poor quality
note that you can parse the text and
further process it in your application
now let's say you have a scanned copy of
a form and you want to analyze the
information included in each field you
could use ocr to capture the text but it
requires additional efforts to extract
the required information
the form parser detects form fields in
the document and returns the data as key
value pairs the form parser can also
detect tables in the document and
distinguish between header and body rows
the document quality processor is
designed to assess the quality of a
scanned document
for example here you can see a scanned
page of an old book that's pretty
difficult to read
the document quality processor output a
low score of
0.004 out of 1.0 and it suggests the top
defect is blurriness
let's return to the document object we
observed previously to see how the
information from the form parser is
stored
the form parser stores the extracted
form fields as an array of key value
pairs in the
document.pages.form fields field of the
document object let's look at an example
form fields dot field name consists of
layout information and values for the
form field name and field value provides
the value for the corresponding key
for example we can see in red here that
the text date was extracted as the field
name and in blue we can see that
september 14 2019 was extracted as the
date value
likewise in yellow name was extracted as
a field name and in green sally walker
is the field value
let's say that you are interested in
getting information about the tables and
the data stored inside the tables
the tables field provides an array of
detected tables on the page
in this example the first row of the
table is considered the header row there
are four body rows representing data
inside the table and the data is stored
inside cells now let's look at a python
code example that shows how to extract
key value pairs from a document object
output from the form parser the doc ai
processing works exactly the same as
with batch or online processing but now
you send the api the processor id for a
form parser
here's accessing the document object
output after processing
next all you have to do is cycle through
all the pages and form fields then
access the content for the field name
and field value
you can also find out how sure the model
is the text is correct using the
confidence value for those fields if you
need it
and here's the extracted data it shows
the keys values and confidence scores in
a tabular format
and that's all for today in this video
we discussed general processors
including ocr form parser and document
quality along with how we can use them
to get detailed structured information
from our documents
next time we'll explore specialized
processors and how we can get even more
information from common document types
now you can try out the form parcel
yourself follow the code lab linked in
the description and as always you can
read more about general processors in
the documentation linked below thanks
for watching and don't forget to like
comment and subscribe
[Music]
you